oh [ __ ]
you bad [ __ ]
we're just fumigating the place to get
the bad spirits out of here
left over from last week don't know what
you go for tonight we're going deep in
the murky waters to start the week off
I'm the right [ __ ] foot in exam
boy I know
[Music]
the [ __ ] roof is on fire [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
uncle Joey here
[Music]
I miss you [ __ ]
[Music]
we gotta go down tonight
[Music]
you
[Music]
you bad [ __ ] uncle Joey here
Sunday February 12 back from the [ __ ]
dead
I missed you [ __ ] but you know
what we gotta take a break from time to
time you gotta get on your own [ __ ]
smoking schedule you follow what I'm
saying it's a beautiful day to be alive
we got the goods tonight we got start as
a debt we got [ __ ] in Bam Bam Bam
we got [ __ ] classic og from
perennial we got [ __ ] I don't know
what this is I can't read without my
glasses it don't really much [ __ ]
matter come on in guys that's it uncle
Joey's doing his thing we had a great
podcast for you coming we got a great
album on [ __ ] nuns high and dry did
you eat that candy boy Georgie type
that's your new name Georgie time it's a
starry death just one that's all you
it's just one star okay that's all you
want to do transmission fluid it's your
choice
it's a Sunday night [ __ ] are starting
a week off on the right [ __ ] foot you
follow me if you're under 18 hang up now
that's number one number two tell
grandma you need some of those [ __ ]
valiums tonight because you're going
deep tonight it's one of those nights
what breaking the ice yeah just eat half
of it just eat happy
oh yeah just eat half of that I forgot
oh no I forgot after how you oh you
could get a piece of transmission fluid
yeah a piece of this a piece of this
look how it comes like a piece of butter
this [ __ ] is the real deal
people we [ __ ] around tonight
look at this seat comes like this when
you pop it
it breaks into four
it breaks into four smallest it's a
transmission fluid it's this what the
double takes for breakfast every day so
which one you want that's less than the
star I just paid two hundred so if I ate
four pieces I even ate a piece of that
load to give you like 40 milligrams huh
if you don't want that with what we got
we got the sugar cubes and we got the
[ __ ] acid oh yeah you know we don't
[ __ ] around
it's Sunday night is the Lord's Day Jack
in a spiritual form is it oh [ __ ]
you put some on your finger and just
write that what do you put on I shoot
you to speed the process you don't want
to do that [ __ ] tonight because then
you'll go back to the room and get
flashbacks of Vietnam we'll need sex
[ __ ] you long Sam oh [ __ ] that TKO was
on fire
Lee and we'll split another one will
sleep like babies tonight you understand
me like [ __ ] babies how so that's
some plata - la de is the paper s the
regular paper stuff so just take a piss
that green [ __ ] that's all you need
that's all you need well listen you can
do heroin you to do all your crazy drugs
you eat a little piece of this
there's you with a little piece of this
that's all you [ __ ] me you'll be put
to pillow you'll be dancing jumping up
and down
this is transmission for
read the manga no let's call they should
just call this Mozgov ah call TKO
we'll just rename it Mazda by [ __ ]
around so see those are the squares if
those are 15 look what I gave you I give
you a 50 you ain't gonna go deep
[Music]
little fella
if you touch that [ __ ] you'll test
positive you touch that [ __ ]
you'll be testing positive here it's
time for some bong hits [ __ ]
we got like I said we got two different
types of wheat we got this classic OG
that's killing [ __ ] and we got
this platinum oh [ __ ] but I got that
sativa that's brutal dry this is the 24k
dry this is brittle this will [ __ ]
kill you right here you take this piece
you pop this like this BAM you take your
little [ __ ] pipe and you go like this
clean this side you give it like a
little hand job like a little stomach
good job and then you fill this in
[Music]
[Music]
leave him alone he's the business I need
his brain sharp hey I'm Sammy
and he's brain sharp he's already deep
enough he's already deep enough Lee
Malone Devils on deal it's either you or
the priest young Sam let's get this [ __ ]
together here it's a good night people I
don't know what you're thinking thank
you for making the CD number one on
iTunes Canada UK you [ __ ] of my
heart without you people to have oh god
see understand Lee this is why I go the
extra mile yeah I don't give a [ __ ] we
sacrifice here we don't [ __ ] around
everybody else is smoking lying to you
go over here pulling it back from 69 we
have two leftover acid from Pink Floyd
I'm saying what have you done with your
[ __ ] life lately
[Music]
this is called the savage look at them
[Music]
that's the savage I put him in a cage at
night we take this again
oh [ __ ] we [ __ ] pop this you take this
[ __ ] you dump it right in here
and we're ready for another bowl just
like uncle Joey sent you that's it - I
know that's the savage we don't think I
forgot about the Stars
[Music]
[Music]
that's the whole thing give me that
little piece back well I'll make that
little piece she's alright I saw you me
[Music]
you go you bad [ __ ] you know I
love you guys on a Sunday night here we
got my man mr. Mozgov are coming in talk
about his fight talk about his future
maybe look at it some street fighting
hey one of the [ __ ] you people want to
do you know I got your back it's Sunday
night I'm gonna start you off on a
Monday morning tip-top Magoo I got
cheated by speech here aka Lisa oh yeah
you ain't blowing clouds like that stop
right now get a paper pen go high only
the [ __ ] friends at starbucks blow
smoke be yourself you [ __ ] we're blowing
it right from the [ __ ] heart you
[ __ ] you understand me
we're blowing it from the hearty and
that's all that [ __ ] matters if
you're not blowing it from the heart
you're faking the [ __ ] pump take the
poster down to the butt on your wall
your Apple back anyway
put a dick and get it over with you
understand me [ __ ] no we don't even read
High Times here we just smoking [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
here's another one for you you filthy
[ __ ] animals I love you
it's the Lord's Day who's better than
you you're smoking dope you're kicking
back you got the world by the balls it's
Monday get a second chance tomorrow if
you [ __ ] up last week [ __ ] it we do it
again tomorrow nobody gets their
feelings hurt
[Music]
I've got this [ __ ] flat the
maze we're gonna try out I got this this
morning early and I left it in the car
all day with the Sun roof the Sun
beating on the weed this is beautiful we
trying weather last week with that
[ __ ] rain
I wasted money smoking wet [ __ ] weed
all week but this shit's on fire tonight
you stick one of these little buds in
yeah so it's all over everything goes
away you take this little bud and stick
it in your little muffler don't never
[ __ ] find you go Saturday night baby
[Music]
[Music]
over here with we understand
and we'll get this party started right a
bowl always has to be around the corner
me I've always worried about that I wake
up in the morning and I'm saying I'm a
little insecure I smoke a ball ahead we
are here we are no this ain't no big
[ __ ] thing you know I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I take - it's been fine I start
writing I get my composure back and I've
realized who the [ __ ] I am
maybe you can't do not mess you know the
[ __ ] you are could you do mine is a
pirate down look at this guy
sky don't [ __ ] around hit the savage
dog-piss savage where's those stars at
death let's finish off those [ __ ]
stars we can't let them right in I'm
saying one
[Music]
he pick up the big bag come on anarchy
aka star one shows up tomorrow with the
big bag about 11 o'clock tomorrow's a
big day here we pick up the shipment
understand Lee
[Music]
what are you gonna do yeah I'll live
your life people you can't sit there
[ __ ] scared I was scared for years
what happened nothing
take a chance Columbus did pop that
[ __ ] back whatever the [ __ ] you got
go down deep tonight you know I'm saying
deep you wake up Monday morning feeling
good looking good Billy Ray and somebody
adventures gonna suck your dick maybe
not today but tomorrow you keep going to
the same person to suck your dick
eventually you'll break them down get
them saying there's not time today
that's right pressure busts pipes baby
we're gonna start this podcast in about
ten minutes go to youtube.com slash c /
Joey Diaz that's that face who the [ __ ]
do you think you're dealing with again
thank you for making the [ __ ] CD
number one on iTunes it's still there UK
Canada I love you [ __ ] always
there don't forget Minneapolis next week
the house of comedy we ain't [ __ ]
around wanna blow up that [ __ ] ball
you understand me don't forget about me
youtube.com
[Music]
ashle /c / Joey Diaz I'll catch you
[ __ ] in ten minutes